I think that bad things are going to
happen to your life and everyone
watching this is the sad truth of it you
could be a sad winner or a sad loser so
go and win every day
so I don't remember ever having any
money or anything good I've had my ups
and downs in life you know the the path
to success isn't one big straight graph
on its way up everyone who hears these
words of mine and does them will be like
a wise man who built his house on the
rock and the rain fell and the floods
came and the winds blew and beat on that
house but it did not fall because it had
been founded on the Rock and everyone
who hears these words of mine and does
not do them will be like the foolish man
who built his house on the sand and the
rain fell and the floods came and the
wind blew and beat against the house and
it fell and a great fall it was my dad
dying was the hardest part for me and
Andrew to go through ever but what you
have to understand with things like that
is you don't actually have a choice
people say this all the time like how
did you deal with that like well what
was what was my alternative bring him
back to life there is no way out of it
you can either and will say this whole
time oh my mother's got cancer she's
gonna die in six months what do I do I
say Enjoy the next six months with her
there are lots of situations in life
where your hands are tied so with Dad
dying it was a simple matter of okay
you can let this destroy you which is an
option and people do this all the time
drink themselves to death I don't know
start cutting themselves whatever stuff
people do to cope with difficult
situations or you can be sad anyway
because you're sad either way so you can
work 18 hours a day not let anything
distract you and stay focused on the
mission so that way you have less time
to think about it and you can be sad
while you're working and then you know
when you start to come to terms with
everything you've got millions of
dollars as opposed to oh I've come to
terms with everything but I'm in a Rehab
Clinic
but there was a year the year when I was
living in that flat and Dunstable when I
couldn't afford the electricity that
year I think for the entire 12-month
period me and Andrew made probably less
than seven or eight grand total so we
ran out of electricity we put an
extension wire in the hallway and ran it
into the apartment to charge our phones
and our computers and stuff and you
couldn't you couldn't close the door
because the wire was too big now that me
and Andrew are in a position
where we can guide young men we can give
young men who perhaps don't have the
guidance they need a direction in life
and we've learned the hard way from
trying different things from coming up
in a very bad way we've learned the hard
way how to live as men
so nowadays when people are reprimanding
me because of when I was 25 I started a
webcam studio and everyone said oh well
you know you shouldn't have done that
well look I was a 24 year old with no
money struggling to pay the bills who
found a completely legal way to run
business as though when I was 25 I was
telling everyone in the world look young
men everyone needs to be like me I can
show you the way but that wasn't my
message back then I was a man trying to
put bread on the table and trying to
make money it's one of the reasons that
me and Andrew always preach about you
know financial success and making money
and all the things that we always talk
about because we understand that as as
ugly as it is I guess that the world
revolves around money in such a way it's
not just the world it's your
relationships your marriages your family
the dynamic you have with your kids it
all revolves around money in one way or
another because it can make things a lot
better and money can also make things a
lot worse but being broke is harder than
being rich and I couldn't do fun things
and I couldn't go to nice bars or nice
clubs the fact that I was a kickboxer
got a lot of attention I could beat
another man up sure the Broke Girls like
that I always had pretty girlfriends so
what are you doing right now if you're
just a normal guy with a normal job
doing nothing you don't produce any
content you're not talented you can't do
gymnastics or play the guitar do
something every dude on Earth and you're
just another one of them unless you make
yourself different in some way you will
never get scoured out I don't think I
found my purpose in life until I was 32.
so I I feel like my purpose in life now
is to set a good example for
young men in a world that doesn't have
any good examples I don't think everyone
is going to reach that level of
Enlightenment with their mission and I
don't think everyone should because when
I was 28 when I was 29 I was very happy
I was perfectly happy having not found
what my purpose in life is and you know
what I may think I know my purpose in
life now when I'm 40 I may realize it
was actually something else and find
something else no I don't believe life
has to be a purpose I just believe in
making sure that you are happy and
making sure that that happiness is
spread as much as possible to the people
you interact with in the people around
you that is a way to live a fulfilling
life you don't have to have a mission to
live a fulfilling life or a purpose you
could live you know basically buy
yourself your whole life but if you
really enjoy yourself and you really
enjoy this trip around the Sun that
we're all taking and everywhere you go
you're polite in your life and your kind
who cares that you didn't impact the
world you know people will always talk
people will always hate on you for well
in life but um yeah if you're a young
man and you've closed your first big
deal and you have your first bit of
money and there's a car you want maybe
it's a BMW maybe it's a Mercedes I would
say with all the financial advisors and
business nerds on Twitter who will tell
me not to say this I would say go out
and buy that car and then that car will
increase your image and then continue
working continue grinding and then buy
more cars to lie and say you never have
more than five friends your whole life
and that was a lot because what you have
to understand is you're walking through
the world hoping to meet these friends
by random by random chance you're going
to run into a guy with the same values
as you the same Mission as you the same
mindset as you the same goals as you
who's aligned in every way you're not
going to meet those people walking
through the world but I now have at
least 30 real friends 35 real friends
why call my real friends before I was 28
I certainly had more hard times a good
time absolutely the last few years have
been exceptionally easy even this one
where they send me to jail it's fine
justice has to be done and now God is
going to make sure Justice is done I'm
going to make sure Justice gets done and
even if they drop the case tomorrow
that's not Justice what 15 months of my
life three months in jail this many
months on house arrest the amount of
money I've lost my reputational damage
if they dropped the case tomorrow is
that Justice I'd be more mad if I didn't
go to prison with him I'd feel like you
know I've taken all the good from being
associated with Andrew and you know he
builds me up and I build him up and for
him to be sitting in jail without me it
would just feel wrong so I'm not even
mad about it I'm the opposite of mad
about it I'm glad they broke me in with
it I'm glad they said Guilty By
Association I'm glad don't be in jail
with them and if they frame him for real
and send him back they better send me
back too or I'll break myself in if
you're gonna if you're gonna walk around
the world running your mouth all the
time about what you are and what you
think you are eventually something's
going to come along the world and test
you you walk around saying I'm the
baddest man on the planet I can beat
anyone up on Earth one day something in
the street is gonna be like ah you're
the guy who thinks he can beat anyone up
and punch your lights out I don't speak
as much as Andrew but I do say I'm a
very strong-minded person I always
preach to young men if you're going
through hardships you need to deal with
it like a man continue your training
stay focused and it just felt like God
gave me an opportunity to prove to to
myself above all else as well as to
everyone else who listens to me that I
am actually what I say I am so coming
out of jail
I'm almost grateful for the experience
as hellish as the environment wants so I
don't want to change anything about my
current situation so if I could go back
in time and change anything in my past I
wouldn't I'm very happy where I am
[Music]